foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at this [ __ ] man uh welcome kids
back to fat man beyond I'm Kevin Smith I
am Mark Bernard hey oh uh as you can see
kids I took a trip back in time to
somebody's basement in the 70s that's
where I'm broadcasting from uh this is
the apartment above uh spot Castle
Cinemas my movie theater my movie
theater where last night Mark we had the
very first inaugural merry Marvel movie
Society screening uh we all watched
Black Panther
and then I got up afterwards and did a q
a for a movie I had nothing to do with
outstanding I'm sure all your answers
were spot on it was tremendous people
literally asked me at one point what
[ __ ] meant in the movie and I was like
to be fair my guess is as good as yours
but here we go and I would break down my
theories and [ __ ] at a certain point it
felt like not so much cultural
appropriation as a directorial
appropriation let me tell you what this
sequence is about exactly uh but I'll
tell you it was kind of cathartic man
you could tell this was an audience
that's like yeah man I would love to sit
in the movie theater and talk about the
movie for like an hour after it was done
when people ask me to describe our
relationship I always say it's two guys
who would go to the movies and then hang
out in the parking lot for two hours
after the movie talking about the movie
we just put a mic in the middle yes so
that feels very on brand
um for for you slash us slash this brand
of geek when you come out Mark is
threatening to come out to smod Castle
for a festival called The Ides of Mark
yes
um we'll have to do you'll be here for a
merry Marvel screening and uh yeah we'll
have to do it man it's good times [ __ ]
it's good times in any event the theater
above the movie theater the movie
theater and the whole [ __ ] Building
in Atlantic Highlands New Jersey kids
is a hundred years old over 100 years
they built this [ __ ] over 100 years
ago
um
back when there were no [ __ ] movies
it was like
Nickelodeons and [ __ ] like hand jobs
that's what I'm talking about a series
of cranking hand jobs were given out in
this building
um so now
um you know the apartment upstairs is
leaves a little you know it's old yeah
to say the least
um so everyone that comes in loves this
paneling but I'm like are you ready for
like you got to keep it I'm like out of
your [ __ ] mind like although there's
an aspect of it that's like I never had
a basement where I grew up we needed a
basement we had a boiler room three
steps off the kitchen where the [ __ ]
boiler was so no basement so I don't
know maybe maybe this is me getting the
childhood I never had
there you go put up a dart board put up
uh I don't know get some shag carpet in
there we're gonna play Twister later on
[ __ ] hey I mean I expect you to start
shooting pornography in there any minute
now I just took up my new betamax Mark
and I'm ready to watch home video movies
[Laughter]
um kids if you see the flickering that's
because I'm trying to light Myself by
candlelight
because I don't have a ring light I
should have [ __ ] went out today and
got a ring light but instead uh I didn't
we're doing it by candlelight it's a
seductive episode of the fat man beyond
I feel like I'm gonna burn my eyebrows
off if I work too close to this one I
feel like the opening of Halloween too
you know the one I grew up with not any
recent version
um
how you been Buddy see I saw you've done
a few black man Beyonds in my absence I
have indeed I've done some black man
Beyonds we had a red Malcolm Barrett on
the show
um Ed Brubaker dropped back and we uh we
had a sort of granular conversation
about writing and the like how he writes
his style his habits
um for both TV and comics and that was
great I mean it's always good to talk to
other writers about stuff true
um and I've been out in the world not as
much as you have needless to say as the
as I see the ongoing uh missives from
the convenience tour dispatches from the
front just badges from front only uh
four shows left I've been doing this
since September 4th
we got four shows left the two in
Phoenix on Sunday
and then on December 5th we're in Boston
at Wilbur
and then December 6th we're at Hartford
Connecticut
and that ends the [ __ ] convenience
tour something I dreamed about doing for
years since the reboot Roadshow tour had
to wait through the pandemic had to make
a whole last movie so that we could take
it on tour and it's been absolute Bliss
I'm gonna miss
uh this tour it it it really was
satisfying and everything and stuff so
if your kids you still haven't seen
clerks three what the [ __ ] is on home
video but if you want to watch it with
yours truly with Silent Bob
uh go to clerks3 dot movie man it's only
Phoenix Boston Hartford
and then we out nice it's been great
life on the road has been wonderful the
audience hasn't been absolute Bliss
every night I go to places where like
people hail me like I'm smart and good
at what I do it's not like the internet
this is the opposite it's real life
and then you go to sleep for two weeks
straight and you get back to L.A I don't
know man I I I'm like I'm working like
uh today I was working on Masters of the
Universe uh which I've now seen
all the animatics for the new season
it's [ __ ] wonderful like oh my god
um then there's another show that me and
Mark are working on that I don't know
that I'm at Liberty to talk about yet
um so uh I was going over the premise
docs for that today and then there's a
show that I'm writing with Harley that
got put aside when I went on tour now I
got to finish that last draft and stuff
so there's a bit of writing I got ahead
of me for the next few days but I'll
tell you right now
I'm in New Jersey
over spawn Castle Cinemas
um tomorrow night I'm gonna go to my
high school my hometown High School
where I went to high school and
performed plays you know and I'm gonna
see the school play which is nine to
five
how amazing is that gonna be that's
awesome nine to five with a bunch of
[ __ ] teenagers it's gonna be nuts
that's my Friday night right there I
look forward to their trenching
commentary on uh on on sort of
Shenanigans in the workplace
like how do you guys feel about sexual
harassment
okay what the show's about and also
murder you know for kids this play is
real It's Gonna Take It real real quick
I think it's probably gonna be like a
waiting for government Affair the moment
the kids get win at [ __ ]
High falutin director Kevin Smith
is going to be in the audience they're
going to turn those performances up man
uh of course
those kids know that I'm in the audience
Mark they're gonna work [ __ ]
eight to ten
eight eight to six careful child labor
laws Kev don't get involved
how delightful is that though man go and
[ __ ] see the high school play that's
good times right there
it will be good times all right good
times are in store for you my friends
because me and Mark Bernard nav off
a [ __ ] ton of [ __ ] to talk about not the
least of which is a little motion
picture called wakanda Forever
also of course be talking about uh
dearly departed loved one who went away
from us and covering a bunch of news all
of that and more lies ahead of you on
fat man beyond the first we pay our
bills indeed and also there's kind of no
news but
I appreciate the hard Sal thank you
who's uh you know what kids let me tell
you right now
this show don't [ __ ] work
without the good Folks at manscape man
it's never too early to play holiday
music it's never too early to start
thinking about gifts whether it's a gift
for a friend or the friends in your
pants
that's right you can make this the
season to be jolly with manscape do your
little do your little drummer boy a
favor and use the lawnmower 4.0 to avoid
another Silent Night
in the bedroom the philosophy is if you
shave your dick you'll get it sucked uh
then head in manscapes top of the line
shower products I blew my candles out
[ __ ] now I'm in the dark myself I was
like myself like a Kubrick movie for a
second there that one's all over
um
then Adam manscapes top of the line
shower products my friends uh and you're
gonna have the people thinking all I
want for Christmas is your manscaped
dick in my face Santa cares about his
sack and so should you that's good
writing oh yeah that's top-notch I take
my hat off to that that's here hold on
I Duff my cap that's [ __ ] good
writing right there look nice when you
get naughty by going to manscaped.com go
right now we'll wait and use the code
fat man all one word for free shipping
and 25 off man tell them about manscape
Platinum package well it's 20 off don't
go giving away percentages we can't give
up I bet what did I say it's a 25 off
a little extra five I put my finger on
the scale a little something something
just for you guys he's right it's funny
the manscape Platinum package 4.0 is a
One-Stop shop for the man who deserves
it all and as everything you need to
help you Deck the Halls from face to
balls it's just in time for the
mistletoe season
that was really strong uh the Platinum
package has each product from the
best-selling performance package plus uh
Ultra Premium body wash Ultra Premium
2-1 shampoo and conditioner and Ultra
Premium deodorant the best way to smell
fresh from your Santa hat to your candy
cane the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer and
weed whacker nose ear and hair trimmer
feature proprietary Advanced Skin safe
technology to protect your delicate
presence plus both at waterproof so
there's no issue clearing the snow out
of your driveway it was about 4 000 LED
light 4 000k LED light on it you can
light the way I put off and now that
you've grown candy cane it's time to
make sure all that you don't smell like
a reindeer but the Platinum package is
shower products all of manscape shower
gear is sulfate free vegan and made to
have your skin feeling hydrated and
smelling fresh but smelling good doesn't
stop at the shower the crop preserver
ball deodorant Viber ball toner can help
solve static problems all day long once
they touch your sack you'll never go
back
the Platinum package 4.0 sitting under
the tree is guaranteed to put anyone in
the holiday spirit and for the perfect
stocking stuffer add in a brand new body
buffer an incredible body scrubber that
makes exfoliating easy and a lot cleaner
than that old Loof
so get 20 off and free shipping with the
code Fatman at manscapes.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use the code Fatman at checkout
manscape get your jingle balls ready for
the holidays
boom
there it is we did it we thank the good
Folks at manscape ladies and gentlemen
for sponsoring
fat man beyond go to manscaped.com
manscaped with a d
indeed.com and patronize the good Folks
at manscape
um I lost my lighting I gotta I gotta
redo my lighting yeah
get a key grip getting the best boy
truly I'm not in the union so I
shouldn't be doing this be careful now
I'm back to
they still use that music in the new
version of Halloween
um I have not seen a new version of
Halloween
um because you know I'm a [ __ ]
um but I'm pretty sure they uh they
don't deviate too far from the John
Carpenter original you're a [ __ ] I'm a
cuck that's what [ __ ] Twitter told me
for 24 hours straight because I had the
audacity mark to post a photo of myself
crying at Black Panther
my God I didn't post myself with uh
crying at Black Panther with the
sentiment uh Trump
2024. I didn't post myself uh crying at
Black Panther with any of the sentiments
that Kanye has popularized lately uh
that is all to say Mark that like it's
the least controversial thing in the
world to post a photo of yourself crying
at a [ __ ] movie that just opened
that's about you know a character and
the actor who passed away is about grief
For Heaven's Sake and my God you would
have thought that I was the problem with
Society with the internet
I mean [ __ ] post got like 30
000 likes but Jesus there are a bunch of
people who are so angry at that like
really angry like people were like look
even if you cry in that movie why the
[ __ ] do you post a picture of it and
[ __ ] and then people were like why would
you even cry in a movie let alone that
movie blah blah it's crazy it really I
became a lightning rod for like 24 hours
I was trending and [ __ ] like that
all over the fact that like I posted a
teary selfie there was more crying done
by people on the internet about my
crying picture than I did when I
actually cried and took the [ __ ]
photo all that query
um
it was uh another reminder of uh that
that there are a lot of cats out there
that just
they don't they're not in their feelings
Mark no no they are not in touch with
their emotions not every and you know
what I ain't saying that's a bad thing
and I'm saying I'm right and they're
wrong but kids accommodate for the fact
that I did survive a [ __ ] heart
attack and I'm a middle-aged Stoner
everything [ __ ] touches me everything
is profoundly [ __ ] beautiful when
you've almost died and [ __ ] so there's
that then also you know when I put up
the video of me crying at the flash man
there's a kid at a con who was like
I like that video you cry in the flesh
and I was like oh you're gonna tease me
about that too and he goes no he's going
my friends beat the [ __ ] out of me
whenever I cry at comic book movies and
I was like yeah my friends tease me too
and he goes no they beat the [ __ ] out of
me literally and then I showed him that
video of you [ __ ] crying they beat me
up a little less and I was like well
there it is man
yes absolutely man it's not everything's
not a [ __ ] movie Mark with a
three-act structure and a [ __ ] just
God becomes Rocky
he just got beat up a little less and
God damn it ain't that enough in this
sick World
Arc of the universe is long exactly you
know what I'm saying
um but oh my God the [ __ ] vitriol
dude the you know good thing I'm white
comfortable in my own skin and [ __ ]
because good Christ people were so angry
so angry that you showed an emotion for
something that they didn't agree with
and [ __ ]
um meanwhile like every night on the
clerks 3 tour it's like I have my
revenge because I make people cry in the
third every [ __ ] night I own the
whole theater and I'll cry I was like
that's what you all get for making fun
of Minecraft however the people in that
audience probably not the ones making
fun of me for crying on the internet a
lot of people if you click on their [ __ ]
they got like under 30 followers and a
lot of it is about you know [ __ ]
let's go Brandon and [ __ ] like that so
right
but man oh man like then there's some
people that are just like why would you
cry at a mid-level Marvel movie and I'm
like this level Marvel movie but I guess
that's something we'll discuss right now
because me and Mark kids
are going to fall down the rabbit hole
of nemour or up the rabbit hole yes the
mutant hole I think we will I I so much
appreciate it that you have been
pronouncing
submariner's name the way he pronounces
his name
which is no more but nobody else in the
movie pronounces it no more they all say
Neymar they will save you anymore even
though he's like dude it's Spanish it's
literally about the child without love
so his name is no more that's how you
would say that it was pretty clear I
thought I mean he told us where the name
came from but it's it's a little bit
like the inside origin man you know none
of that [ __ ] was classic Marvel right
like I know yeah it's all just made up
they all made it up I mean look it's all
made us yes this is a new iteration it's
all made out but it's a little bit like
yeah Los felis is not how you say that
word we've just decided that that's how
you say it right your name or no more
name more and more
they're not how do you say that word
I'm here
Banff
hey look here it's [ __ ] bamf man
[ __ ] coming in everybody's well I
haven't seen Batman in a red hot minute
how you doing JC good I was just gonna
throw out their uh how do you like my
lighting solution
I dig it uh will Wilkins was texting
what do you think of my solution
that's my [ __ ] Spock when he's dying
I knew yeah I knew [ __ ] Bernard
yeah put it on the glass
will said your uh sound is very warm due
to the wood paneling behind you
sounds good my salad is Rich and warm
yeah
these are the basement tapes kids I'm in
my [ __ ] 70s basement up here the
irony is I'm not downstairs I'm as high
as you can get on the second well I'm as
high as you can get but I'm as high as
you can get because I'm on the second
floor in Atlantic Highlands that's as
high as you go
I'm living like the Kingpin up here I'm
living like [ __ ] remember when Bruce
Wayne had the apartment in the city and
[ __ ]
patinson Wayne that's right
if there's a tower Crusader running
around Highlands we know where his first
place we're gonna look is exactly
they're like you know that guy the
Vigilante showed up when you started
hanging out here
that's just a coincidence I'll play the
old comic angle where I'm like I happen
to be very good friends with the
Vigilante and he told me
what's your superpower he cries you to
sleep
[Laughter]
washes the bad guys away in a river he
drowns you in tears he's like when
you're like no
he waterboards you with his tears nice
yeah
I popped in to say the name or no more
conversation sounds a lot like Princess
Leia or Princess Leia or Han or Han
solo
I feel you which is this debate that's
been raging on the uh I think the
official Star Wars explanation was uh
people from different parts of the
Galaxy pronounce it different ways
uh speaking of the people from different
parts of the Galaxy y'all still in for
Andor I haven't I haven't caught up yet
I've been showing clerks through
everywhere so I'm two weeks behind
yeah I'm I'm still at week two yeah I'm
all cut up and it only gets better is
that right yeah it it's it's [ __ ]
magnificent
I mean there's there's and some of it is
the big stuff some of it is like oh [ __ ]
we're doing like Space Battles well hey
there's some aliens that's cool oh it's
a prison break neat and then sometimes
it's just super [ __ ] small just
seeing work just actors working at the
top of their craft and and writing
that's that delivers everything you want
to and just the the the angle that it
takes on what it costs to Stage a
rebellion what's the price you know Tony
Gilroy is very concerned with how do you
make a rebellion app what is an
Insurgency or what money and will and
how do we get the money and that's the
one part of it
which you'll discover as you as you go
deeper in her and then the will is how
do we make a people angry enough to
revolt and it's it's just fascinating
getting under the hood of that
I'm going to put them up on the big
screen it's modcastle that'll watch it
put it up on a big screen that's also
the best review Mark has ever given on
this show yeah you're not kidding oh my
god let's [ __ ] pour one out for the
fact that
Mark's no longer hateful Mark he's
[ __ ] loving Mark that is a powerful
review every every at the end of every
year we do a top 10 list of [ __ ] that we
liked and it does it does bear out that
I do like something
my face
I will say curiously earlier in chat
somebody named Mark B with a uh generic
icon said who is this Kevin guy and why
is he on black man beyond
don't know if we're tempting playing
with the algorithm there but curious it
was Mark B who said that
says clerks 3 was a better movie than
wakanda I don't it's a completely
different movie he says hard watching
Kevin's chill and not be himself why
like
there's nothing more myself than liking
a Marvel movie
seriously as the guy who lives every
[ __ ] day with Kevin Smith I mean and
check the internet like I got the
receipts like how is this Shilling
[ __ ] they need no help [ __ ]
got Disney money and [ __ ] why can't I
like a Thing Mark without being accused
of being a [ __ ] shill I wish they
would [ __ ] pay me man that'd be
amazing but I just like it for free my
am I doing it wrong
liking it for free am I supposed to shut
up and like it here's the thing you'll
never hear about something I don't like
I'll tell you about everything that I
[ __ ] love
like and what they want to hear is hey
this [ __ ] stupid goddamn internet
machine all they want is me it'll be
like I hate this and this is shitty and
this person [ __ ] sucks you ain't
gonna get that from me man all you're
gonna get is love I [ __ ] love these
Marvel movies don't take that away from
me it's not [ __ ] Shilling I ain't
even telling people to go
am I did you hear me say oh you must
[ __ ] go no I just told you what I
[ __ ] felt get off my dick
but if you do go see it at smodco
smodcast Cinemas yeah well done thank
you Jersey thank you let me jump a shot
from my own movie theater nobody if if
you end everything with that nobody can
ever complain you'll just be like I'm
trying to make a [ __ ]
they'll find something to complain about
they [ __ ] about that too some
[ __ ] told me like uh we're doing
this mod Castle Film Festival
Ernie tells me Ernie you know is my
friend and uh Partners podcast and stuff
smodcast keeper Ernie O'Donnell
uh you know he's the one program the
festival [ __ ] he all brokenhearted
because he's like there's some guy who's
got a movie in the festival and he's on
some website gone this is a vulgar cash
grab by [ __ ] Smith
and Ernie's like Smith's got nothing to
do with it we're we're gonna lose money
doing this
I was like dude you don't understand the
internet they don't need facts your [ __ ]
[ __ ] your facts it's all about their
[ __ ] feelings and [ __ ] it's crazy
dude like how people will like literally
try to tell you like Gaslight you into
[ __ ] believing in unreality you know
it's like all those [ __ ] that were like
you know uh oh the only reason they
renewed Masters the universe because it
was happening before the renewal it's
not [ __ ] true at all only reason we
got a renewal on is because we got the
numbers but they don't want to say that
because that goes against their [ __ ]
narrative or whatever so weird when
people try to tell you like I had some
[ __ ] like telling me that clerks 3 was
unsuccessful it's like you want me to
put up any more photos of [ __ ] packed
houses you're out of your [ __ ] mind
like you're gonna Gaslight try with
facts like can't tell the guy who was
there with photo proof that [ __ ]
things aren't working ugh internet is so
[ __ ] disgusting sometimes man I think
uh I'm gonna stop reading the internet
yeah like
but you know what I'd rather like do
something like we did last night we did
the merry Marvel movie Society everyone
in the room could have their [ __ ]
sight you know it wasn't people asking
me questions about the movie it was a
lot of people just going like here's
what I thought and [ __ ] like that
um you know that's I'm all for that
because guess what I asked the room man
I was like how many people like the
movie hands went up how many people
didn't like the movie No Hands went up
because how many people felt like there
were some good scenes but it ain't Black
Panther and a couple hands went up and
[ __ ] like that and a hate tank in the
real world you know what I'm saying it's
like
people just people get to be people in
the real world online there's anonymity
so they're just like I'm gonna write the
worst [ __ ] thing ever and it's like
well try to make it make sense so weird
now he's come at me with hate and I just
kind of use their tweets to sell a thing
like
seems ridiculous to me it seems like a
ridiculous waste of time but
that's how people and and you know I
hate to be this guy but it's like
you know the secret to [ __ ] being
somebody that gets paid to like make
pretend for a living is
don't waste your creativity
[ __ ] spending a day lacerating me for
liking black panther so much that I
[ __ ] squirted speaking of black
panther should we just talk about it
let's just talk about it
um
I think I've mentioned the the last
black movie on I think it was the solo
show
um that I did after going to the
premiere that's sort of my feelings
about the movie were very much colored
by being in the house you know Premiere
audiences yeah how did you first off how
did you get to go to the premiere I I
was a friends plus one like I still have
enough connects in journalism world that
I can have you know just reach I was
like hey you go to them yeah
and uh and then hit you on somebody's
cocktails for that Marvel is not
inviting me
um despite our prodigious Shilling for
Marvel they don't we get nothing in
return for all of our show
um which makes it not chilly
um and so the the way that I felt coming
out of the theater was it's a very
emotional experience that it's awake for
both a character t'challa and then after
Chadwick Boseman
um with a little bit more distance from
it I've now seen it twice that's what it
wants the Maryland once earlier this
week
um I still do believe that when that's a
movie that's engaging with that core
wound
I think it's pretty remarkable I think
that the way in which they pivoted from
what was a completely different movie
like I'm sure no more was still the
antagonist but the entire rest of that
film the rest of the Contours of that
movie feel like they're very much
defined by the loss of chattered both
and so the work to make that real let's
make it fundamental and to make it what
the movie is about which is can shuri
engage with that grief and will that
grief drive her angry will it make her
want to work
um and can she come back from that to be
the Regent that wakanda needs
um I think it's great I I I am not as in
love with the parts that are about
every Ross or or Val de Fontaine unless
enthused with the shield of it all
um Ruby Williams didn't really work for
me only because she felt very much like
a backup and the we want to get out of
wakanda we need to go and get a thing
let's have it baby Williams you know but
she's not a character yet she's just
kind of a device
um and so whenever we're out in that
world with her I was just a little like
okay I mean I guess we'll have a car
chase here like I don't really care that
much but sure all right
um and I think the neighborhood stuff is
pretty great excuse me no more that's
what you talked about it tells us a
thousand times how to say his name and
we're all just going to pretend like he
doesn't say it
um
I really enjoyed the the
recontextualization of that myth of
hello Khan and the sort of the
Mesoamerican influences and you know the
origins that like yeah he's absolutely a
Offspring a byproduct of vibranium out
in the world and so he added a black
panther are connected in a certain way
um
but the man alive like
seeing it even again there were moments
where I I like you Kev just shed a tear
um more than one tear I mean the whole
opening sequence I think we we
postulated a version of that sequence
like a year ago of the Sherry's big
problems might be that she couldn't save
her brother
that's her wound like the smartest
person in all of wakanda couldn't do the
thing that she used let me let me tell
you something like her performance
Leticia Wright her performance is so
[ __ ] good in that opening scene and
throughout the whole movie she's
wonderful
she makes you forget that she was like
you know I'm not wearing a mask remember
she was like yeah she's in trouble at
one point because she was all like
anti-lover anti-vaccine or whatever and
I you know forget all of that from that
opening scene which is so like intense
and brings you right into a situation
which spoilers I mean we have to be able
to talk about yeah it's been out for a
week you know and we feel like we've
given it to the good grace
um that scene
one what an insanely powerful way to
open the movie and instantly
create tension and it's like fighting a
villain that you can't punch in the face
yeah oh it's not like oh [ __ ] it's
Thanos we got to get the glove off him
you're fighting
you know poor health dying a failing
body uh and she's the smartest person in
the room and
can't pull it off and oh my God she
conveys
the grief so insanely [ __ ] well like
give her a nod man she you know that's
uh it was it was heartbreaking to watch
her go through
the losses of her brother you know I I
think she was acting her ass off in that
movie yeah absolutely and to go from
that opening scene to the Marvel logos
with only Chadwick with no score just
try just really really hard to get
through that that was instantly I was
already crying from the opening scene
and then when they [ __ ] rolled him in
the Marvel logo it's like come on yeah
yeah it was an emotional affair that's
why I was so [ __ ] gobsmacked that
people were like what are you crying for
I'm like whether you like that movie or
not whether you think it's top tier
Marvel or not
how do you not [ __ ] feel the emotion
of that movie The Man's gone and like he
had a choice they could have made two
different movies right I mean they could
have made a bunch of different movies
but you hire somebody new to be the
Black Panther and you just tell a black
panther sequel Story the same way there
have been multiple James Bonds multiple
Batman multiple Spider-Man
or you do something
that honors the passing of the the man
who played the part like all those
people were family you know they were
all tight with you we're all Chadwick
Boseman fans you know everybody Brian
coogler all the way down Kevin feige and
everyone on the crew they're practically
family
so in a world where
you know they lose
their brightest star and can't do what
originally was intended
unless they just hire somebody else to
be the Black Panther
I you know
I I kind of dig their choice like you
know I
I know it's not
what everybody thinks of when they're
like we're gonna go see a Marvel movie
you know a lot of it was
slow and about [ __ ] grief and
acceptance and stuff and they tried to
keep it moving with some action
sequences but
they tried to do something
different and unexpected and I salute
that 100 percent
um did it all work for me you know some
of it was slow you know look I'm on
record
I like my movies 90 minutes
um but I'll watch a two-hour movie but
when you get above two it's like you
better be
super [ __ ] special
um you better be doing things that
nobody else is doing and stuff so
you know could it have been shorter
absolutely could they have done with
some a few less characters you know
maybe
but
I you know I was never bored I watched
it twice uh I paid to see it in Oklahoma
and then I watched it for free and smart
Castle Cinemas last night for the Marvel
the merry Marvel movie Society screening
um you know and there are definitely
Parts where it's like
Moving on but
I you know I in a world where you could
have made a different Choice altogether
and just like all right let's keep doing
the movie we're gonna make
you know I think it's kind of special
that they
they did what they did like it's like a
200 million dollar wake yeah and you
know I know maybe some people like well
I don't want to pay to see a 200 wake I
want an adventure story you know well
they were they did too and they're just
playing the ball where it lays for them
I mean it's the end of phase four
um I there's folks in the screening last
night somebody asked like
how come they're not setting things up
like you know first phase one and two
there was this sense of dread with
Thanos is coming and
like where's all that and I was like
well it looks like it's going to be Kang
coming soon
um so that's all going to kick in but it
felt like here
that they were like
you know let's let's not use this movie
to be like and coming soon a new bad guy
you know they like they didn't even go
to final scene they just did the
mid-credits scene which for my money was
hands down the best part of the movie
you could have just shot that scene and
charged me double the C
you know and that was the movie and then
ran full credits after it without even a
mid-credit scene and I would have
[ __ ] been happy with it like that
that was profoundly wonderful as a
writer I was ashamed that I didn't see
it coming but as an audience member I
was so [ __ ] delighted by that scene I
thought it was really powerful that they
ended the movie the way they did with
Sherry on the beach just [ __ ]
thinking about Chadwick and the brief
montage and then slowly the smile comes
across her face I was like that's
profoundly [ __ ] beautiful
um you know way to end a major motion
picture and then when they came back and
did what they did I was like
yeah I mean I I had been on record and I
still believe it that I and I suppose
it's the it's the the the the binary of
should you recast t'challa or should you
kill t'challa out of respect for
Chadwick and I was always in a
I would feel awful if there were
children who got to grow up who didn't
have the challah in their lives you know
t'challa as a character should persist
should exist and so if that's the binary
then I was always in favor of I would
like a new person to be there
um because it'd be a shame if he wasn't
um I didn't see that third option coming
which is yeah no we killed t'challa as
we knew him but there is going to be a
t'challa going forward there is going to
be a prince of wakanda maybe a king of
wakanda like you will still if you're
born today you'll be in a world winner
to child exist and I thought that was an
incredibly elegant solution
to that to that problem
um to the t'challa problem you know and
I think that that I did see
um online there's a there's a tick tock
or a guy named Straw Hat goofy
um who talked about how phase four was
actually all about passing of the men
it was about you know Doctor Strange
passing to America's job is it was about
the two Spider-Man passing the the
mantle onto onto to to the young young
we lad
um Peter Parker it was about
um Clinton Barton passing on to Kate
bishop and it's now about
here's the nude shower that we will get
in
however many years you want to go we're
about to be in a very multiversal time
traveling Zone anyway
so and if these movies are going to take
six years to happen then there's no
reason that kid can't be 19 years old
the next time we come back to a black
man
um and so that feeling of we are now
we're we're overturning the way things
are gone I mean hell even loving Thunder
is about hey look here's a new young
woman who's going to be raised by by
Thor like to help carry that mantle
she'll have the [ __ ] Hammer too
because why not
um and I think that's very powerful
that's very moving and it definitely
crests us into the next phase which is
oh [ __ ] now who are these young Heroes
going to have to deal with you know who
who's the big bad and it's Kang and it's
a secret Wars you know there's some
rumor going around that Kevin feige's
been spending the last couple of weeks
calling everybody who's ever been a
superhero ever
and being a stupid woman
um yeah because if they're going to do
it then they've got to [ __ ] do it for
real so
um you know I I think that that's it's a
very astute observation that that's what
this has been about because I also have
been like what has this been for what's
what's been the initiative what's been
the work that this face is doing and if
it's that then I get it
then I get it it's setting the table for
who is going to fight in a secret War to
come
um but yeah I mean I I there there are
parts of this movie that I love dearly I
love
as a person of Haitian dissent to see us
spend some time in Haiti and like not
the Haiti that everybody gets to see on
TV which is war-torn impoverished
disease-ridden earthquake sufferers it's
a Tropical Paradise which is it's the
Haiti of a child because that's also the
version that I remember from when I
visited when I was like 14 against just
tropical and gorgeous of the people in
lovely and for us to be there for us to
be where Nikia decides to open up her
school and to introduce us to even
though we don't get an info and we see
young Toussaint as one of the students
in her room in her in her class
we see ramonda walk up holding his hand
because she's met
you know I mean I think that that stuff
is gorgeous and lovely and and what a
great use what a great place to set
wakandan Outreach Embassy in a place
like Haiti
um you know I think getting to visit
talukan and seeing what that looks like
um I think it's also certainly gorgeous
and I think you know ten acuerta who
plays nemour is phenomenal like he's got
such magnetism and such energy and
there's such gravitas
um I mean if I had one quibble about the
way that sort of third Act of the way
that movie played out
is that I kind of wanted Nemours thing
to also be about vengeance and also be
about balancing the scales
I mean his is more like well we're just
gonna conquer because we know they're
coming for us now so let's conquer them
first
and so to have some version where when
they get to their final climax on the
beach again spoilers
for them both to have to lay down the
the hammer of of Revenge of trying to to
make it right
um in favor of caring for their people
um it's a little one-sided by the time
you get to that third act but but yeah
man like similarly I I enjoyed the movie
um I never once looked at my watch the
first time I saw it which is a testament
to a two hour and 41 minute movie
um but there's definitely parts of it
that I was more engaged with than others
um but yeah while we were while we were
living in the Wake while we were
wrestling with that idea of what it
means to rule what we're wrestling with
you know
um who sure it goes to see when she
visits the ancestral realm for the first
time
um which I did not see coming
um the uh I mean I I knew he'd make an
appearance I just didn't think it'd be
there that was pretty
that was a good choice yeah you know and
the the way they withheld Chadwick you
know t'challa like you you see him in
the Marvel opening credits and then
that's it it's not until Sharif can
engage with him that the movie engages
with
and so to have that moment where you get
the the council from killmonger and the
council she's getting more counsel from
t'challa's previous enemies than she
does from her friends
um you know between umbaku and and uh
and killmonger I thought all of that
stuff is great like the the you know
staring down the barrel of who do you
want to be like I can't be that person
yet
and I'm angry and the anger is what has
led me to this version of the dark side
it's the it's the you know Luke going up
into the cave to do battle with uh the
big of a gift into battle with his
father
but again this is the you that you are
and you just can't admit it yet here's
the truth of you
and you haven't been confronted with it
yet
I thought all that stuff is fantastic
um but yeah like I'm I'm mixed positive
on it yeah I agree I would say the same
thing
Robert Rojas and Chad said the seven
films of the mcu's phase four explored
answers to Visions question what is
grief but love persevering
are what are the seven films
um black panther is definitely about
great like mentioned the last one no way
home
um fundamentally about grief yeah
um I don't know if you get that out of
Shang Chi
um
it doesn't feel like it's about grief
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange I mean
it's about it's about the the the
pathless the path's not taken right it's
about a long division definitely about
grief One Division about grief
um Hawkeye about grief
[Music]
um
um
I don't know if Loki I guess
what are the movies that we had like the
love and Thunder
maybe that's all that's about grief
yeah
of course Jane
yeah I mean it it it's a it's about it's
about grief on the page I think but uh
but I feel like and we discussed it when
we talked about the movie tonely
it is also light and also chunky
everyone in chat is talking about in
Shang Chi his dad's grief about his
wife's death that he caused
grief does [ __ ]
kind of drive that one as well
Black Widow had a grief aspect so did it
turn
[Music]
interesting interesting like look I'm
here for it because I'm a 52 year old
man but like probably fell action
figures on Grief you know yeah yeah and
you know I think grief is a lever that
you can adjust you know uh up and down I
think yes there's grief in almost every
heroic storytelling because being a hero
is about choice and there's always the
choice that you didn't make and the
ramifications of that choice so like
Shang Chi is not a hero activated by
grief really this grief in his life sure
he lost his mom when he was younger
um but it's not about the losing of
something it's not even about the
immediate wake of that it's about
unresolved father-son issues whether
it's about grief
um
you know She-Hulk doesn't feel like it's
about grief
um unless it's the loss of the life he
used to have in favor of the life you
have now but that's also is a bit
ethereal
I guess
um
I mean what if is all about loss and all
about choice right
um sometimes in the face of the loss we
didn't have which is hey look there's
there's t'challa again
what about
um
why do you think they didn't call
Atlantis
um I mean somebody
some of it is like I mean DC the the one
thing DC got to First was calling it
Atlantis but it's also do you think
largely that was it
I think it's that but there's also no
cultural specificity to Atlantis
right you know like it's it it has
belonged to almost every version of of
myth and culture since and so it's kind
of diffused but by giving it a real like
and if it's not going to be Greek
which is the other way to go then like
all right well what could it be you know
every and it's also enough of a of a
even if you don't call it Atlantis there
is a sunken city myth the same way
there's a flood myth the same way there
are you know Monster myths
um to just deciderate where are we gonna
where are we gonna set what's
interesting who's got an old culture
that we've never seen before
I'm sorry man Archibald bunker says
Charlie Brown is all about that good
grief
[Laughter]
Me and Charlie Brown man we're all about
that good yeah but I'm not complaining
I'm happy that we had the grief and you
know that Marvel gave us grief but
it's time they got back to work and
started making [ __ ] fun adventure
stories right
you know I think I I think it does
require a I mean this was the 30th
Marvel movie
um so like that sort of thing requires a
bit of a roller coaster a little bit of
an ebony flow and did we need seven
installations of grief probably not but
I think it's a it's it's a necessary
color with which you need to paint Bob
Ross would tell us it would be happy
little black in order to get us over to
the happy little clouds that we're gonna
get to later
um
yeah man I uh
uh Lloyd Sharma said Kevin I'm sorry if
I missed this how many times you find
yourself crying during the movie uh I
cried in the beginning when he when he
died off camera died and that was more
about Leticia Wright's performance
triggered me like
seeing somebody be that [ __ ]
heartbroken man oh and pulling it off
where you're like I'm gonna I'm fairly
empathetic so like if somebody's crying
you I'm [ __ ] crying with them and
[ __ ]
um the rest of the movie not so much
until the end sequence when she was on
the beach first by herself and then they
you know it's tough to not get emotional
when they show their flashback footage
of him and of Chadwick and then her
perfect little performance you know and
the Sun hitting her face and her that
smile finally like kind of breaking out
and stuff of acceptance and like yeah
that was my brother and he's gone but I
love him and stuff
that that definitely got me emotional so
I was already like kind of wet-eyed when
they got to the mid-credits scene and
then I was like you know as soon as I
saw the kid in the background I was like
oh Christ felt again felt stupid as a
writer because I'm like
how did I not see this coming a million
miles away but I was so glad man I'm so
I'm you know
I'm 52 man I've [ __ ] seen it and all
done it all [ __ ] it all like
the fact that a [ __ ] thing could
still make me feel anything and some
Make Pretend [ __ ] like
I [ __ ] that's what I pay the money
for like my [ __ ] make me feel
something I'm in the [ __ ] make
pretend business so people give me money
to make them feel something they've been
doing it this whole [ __ ] clerks three
tour and stuff so I understand I give
Marvel my money to make me feel
something and [ __ ] and that made me feel
something like her performance
you know that smile Crossing her face or
in the beginning like when you know her
mom's like your brother is with the
ancestors and she just that that grief
was so [ __ ] real so beautifully
portrayed like
hats off I love people that are
exceptional at what they do and that was
an exceptional performance so you know
was it perfect was it the Black Panther
too that like we thought we'd get when
we first watched black panther no but
man what a beautiful movie about
losing and letting go
which you know a major Studio made
like
normally people are up in arms at the
studio don't do something like this like
why can't they make something real and
here they did that but you know you
can't please everybody
and you know the thing that I also that
got me about that final the mid-credit
Stinger was the notion that as Nakia
says
t'challa prepared us for his death yeah
then like the last year of his life he
spent it in Haiti with his son and his
you know I don't know what the
appropriate term for what Nakia is to
him I don't think it's husband and wife
but at least at least girlfriend
um and that's a story we will never
get to hear
you know and I do sort of love it that
it promises story that that's rich and
is deep and he's emotional and what is
what is that process
what is that what is that ritual like
there was a uh where I gotta find it
because the [ __ ] baby left oh man I
think
the JC maybe deleted or something but uh
it's the guy some guy said no more not
[ __ ] anybody made me tear up
did you see the shot that went around
Twitter of uh of of Tena juerta in his
uh and his little tidy green Underpants
like digging balls full out there for
the world to see and then they cut to
like the oh no this was in the movie
where they shaved it all down
it's like imagine being a guy coming out
of his dressing room and Kevin feige is
going we're gonna get rid of that thick
and balls they really so they had to
tone it down and yeah
in the comics he is like you know this
is a guy that's always trying to steal
Sue storm and [ __ ] he is constantly like
on the make and whatnot
um he did yell in Furious Rex at one
point he did
you got it
I was wondering was shaving dick and
balls
manscape everybody manscape
absolutely just like no more you need to
shave a little of your dick and balls
off if you're Kevin feige you reach for
manscapes our sponsor of first half of
the evening manscaped .com my friends
yes
manscape not known for actually shaving
dick and or balls off
um so yeah that's that's that's sort of
where I come down
on the wakanda forever of it all
uh there it is
and I think Angela Bassett like is
probably going to get some kind of
nomination
um even just for two [ __ ] scenes in
this movie you know the scene where she
explains on that Riverside to to shuri
her process of grief you know just a
sort of tender
um
Council she tries to to advise her
daughter who's still wounded and then
when akoya gets fired
and she just [ __ ] opens the
floodgates
my entire family is gone
have I not given everything
are you allowed to do the voice
I I think if if there's one of us who
can
be like oh if one of us is doing the
voice it's definitely me
um
the uh I can't believe they let him keep
the wings on his feet if they did and
she pulled one of them off too
[ __ ] that was metal as [ __ ] like a
kitty clipping a bird man
and it looked like it hurt him too he
was like
um yeah all right there's your there's
your black panther too what kind of
forever what's the next Marvel
Ant-Man looks like kind of dark right
like it looks like there's some Menace
there looks like something bad's gonna
happen
I'm here for it I want I want some bad
[ __ ] to happen
it's it's a little bit be like here's
the dumb kid who thinks she's doing
something smart and it's like I made a
beacon into the quantum grounds you did
what no
whoops we're going
and then it does it feels oddly like
dark and fun at the same time when it's
like we're going to a Cantina there's a
bunch of weird aliens down here
I hope it's [ __ ] dark man I hope it's
just like him you know Kang like [ __ ]
this like the devil just we've nobody
talking about Mephisto anymore because
he's just like [ __ ] the Devil Himself
man trying to tempt Scott Lang had given
up on the [ __ ]
on the on the present or the whatever
the [ __ ] because he's going to offer up
some time travel [ __ ] ah look I'm here
for it go ahead
uh I just hope Rick Moranis shows up
explain
the kids in the Multiverse of the
quantum realm with all that time for
that guy to get out of retirement what a
perfect way to do it
fair enough
now they already got Bill Murray I don't
know if they're going to also manage to
get another Ghostbuster in there
um
Beast last uh pointed out there's the
Guardians Christmas special coming up
that is also true trademark says if Rick
Moranis didn't show up for Ghostbusters
he won't be back he's coming back for
the Honey I Shrunk the Kids sequel
though is he really yeah he's he's he's
so he stopped acting because he wanted
to be a dad to his kids but his kids are
grown it was 20 years ago so he's
first movie back is the Honey I Shrunk
the Kids sequel
Eric Burch goes so five minutes ago
Kevin Smith said he wanted Marvel to
give away from grief and now he says he
wants Ant-Man to go super dark how much
darker can you go than Greek Empire
Strikes Back dark man where shit's Bleak
and whatnot like [ __ ] Infinity War
dark like
I want some steaks back man and it seems
like Kang is gonna [ __ ] with them it
seems like he's gonna be around for a
while and
I hope he's just I I hope he's
I hope he's just [ __ ] such a badass
I don't have High Hopes mark
it's all right I think I think it's
those folks are founded seems like
Jonathan Majors is committed to being a
badass
um speaking of which [ __ ]
the
Creed trailer hmm
have you seen it
yeah the one that Michael B Jordan
directed yep
seems unfair to be like young and
[ __ ] beautiful and talented and also
good at directing but a lot of actors
are good at directing they you're
talking about a kid who's sat behind a
lot of directors during the wire growing
up yeah Ryan coogler through three
movies at least and stuff he's gone to
film school and based on the trailer he
is ready like [ __ ] that movie looks good
man yeah you know and you know that like
I I believe it to my soul that Stallone
whispered in his ear like if you ever
wanted to direct you make them let you
direct the next Creed movie like they
will want to make that it's like that's
how I got to direct they wanted a rocky
too and I told him that's right well let
me tell you it was no charity because
based on the trailer it's [ __ ]
stunning visually stunning like yeah
compositions there the directions there
it's intense looks fine the story looks
[ __ ] great
I thought for some reason I thought it
was like the son of clever Lang or
something isn't it wasn't that I was
hoping it was the son of clever maybe we
were all kind of wishing it after the
Ivan Drago at all but I'm I'm here for
this story [ __ ]
it's it's a great [ __ ] trailer
yeah I'll be there
um hey uh JC throw up the comic book
stuff would you
um uh this is uh we rarely get to do
comic book talk but look at that that's
the cover to quick stops number four
which uh quick stops number one is in
stores now but if you're ordering comic
books kids
that's tomorrow I think is the last day
look at that cover right there
um in this issue
of quick stops uh Dante takes Veronica
on a second date and uh Randall insists
on going and they go to the Hicks family
reunion so you know Brian o'hollern
played Dante Hicks and clerks but he
played uh Gil Hicks in Mall Rats uh Jim
Hicks and Chasing Amy and Grant Hicks in
Dogma so in this issue at the Hicks
family reunion it's just nothing but
Brian so the cover as you saw was a
breakfast club homage of a bunch of
Brian o'hollorns and one Jeff Anderson
um so fill out your previews folks
uh it's uh
today today or tomorrow is the last day
to pre-order that book in your local
comic shop or you get it from Secret
Stash press of course kev's Comics club
we send you Comics you never miss an
issue
and go find out about that at the secret
stash website or Jay and Silent bob.com
but uh it's been selling like crazy like
you know we've had masquerade out
masquerade issue three you got the
Masquerade art there JC
masquerade issue 3 comes out this week
we got a secret stash exclusive cover by
Chris McDonald uh but this is one of the
other covers look at that [ __ ] look at
that look how [ __ ] violent that is
man that's my vigilante book
with uh Andy mcelfresh and and uh John
springelmeyer captain ripman
um but uh you know quick stops
uh number one is out and it has been
selling like [ __ ] crazy black and
white book
um but you know the Anthology
stories and us coming off click clerks
three every night on tour we sell out of
our copies and stuff so uh if you're
looking for uh you know to order quick
stops for quick stops Issue four
tomorrow I think is the deadline over at
previews get yours that's the other
cover
uh then there's a third cover that'll be
the secret stash exclusive cover I've
been having a blast with the [ __ ]
Comics man
um and I know some people are probably
like ew gross he's talking about his own
[ __ ] but they are comic books for [ __ ]
sake and this is a show about comic
books hosted by a guy who wrote These
comic books so be shocked I'm not
talking about it every damn day every
episode proud of my comic books man I
worked hard to get my own goddamn comic
book label I went into Dark Horse man I
said please
whose dick do I gotta suck to get me a
secret stash press they pointed in the
direction of the dick I sucked it and
here we are
Alex came out
yes and that's Comics kids
um should we do our other AD
yeah let's do that because
after this it's gonna get uh
it's gonna get a little sad
uh folks the second half the last half
of the show
um is gonna be sponsored by the good
Folks at Blue Jew
that's right man uh try Bluetooth when
you use our promo code Fatman at the
checkout just pay five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth.com
with the promo code Fatman
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com and you're gonna
receive your first month free visit
bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information what is
Bluetooth you're asking yourself well
kids
Mark's going to tell you
don't choose a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable tablets at a fraction of the
cost you take them anytime day to night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises the
process is simple sign on to
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days
the best part is all done online it's no
business to a doctor's office no awkward
conversations you know waiting in line
at the pharmacy
the nights are getting longer but the
breeze isn't the only thing that's
getting stiff and that's right we're
talking about bleach you and we know
that confidence can take you far in life
and that's especially true in the
bedroom especially it's time to step up
to the plate so if you could lose use if
you could what about that if you could
benefit from extra confidence when it's
time to perform chew it and do it have
but have better sex and we've got a
special deal for our list struggling to
free we use our promo code Fatman a
checkout just make five dollars shipping
that's bluetooth.com
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code Fatman to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details on
important safety information and as
always we thank bleach you for
sponsoring this podcast
we do thank you to the good Folks at
Blue chew bluetooth.com kids
and old kids
okay
um
uh we lost some people this week kids
Kevin O'Neill was an amazing comic book
artist
who did martial law
one of my favorite [ __ ] comic books
of all time the one that got one of the
books got me back into comic books
didn't he also do League of
Extraordinary Gentlemen as well indeed
yeah brilliant [ __ ] book with Alan
Moore like
oh my God what a talent he was
um and he passed away anybody know how
old he was
um I don't think he was terribly old I
don't have an exact number on it but
it's not like he was in his 90s
um I believe he was in his 60s so too
young way too young man and such a
talented individual kids I know we spend
a lot of time talking about
the movies the TV shows and whatnot but
all this [ __ ]
sources right back to
uh the comic books for heaven's sakes
and so
um is that 20 minutes so your heart out
indeed here we go
um
so um yeah
remember the comic books you know Kevin
O'Neill
um
doesn't get the
the the uh
thought of because you know he he didn't
get in front of a camera or whatnot but
his work
but is it is incredible incredibly
powerful in the medium where most of
this [ __ ] is taken from in the first
place he was a hero of the page
beautiful [ __ ] work man detailed
crazy work go look at an issue of
Martial law yeah the amount of [ __ ]
material he crammed into a [ __ ] panel
the amount of jokes the amount of like
disturbing asides
crazy wonderful book crazy talented man
Kevin O'Neill according to Kabuki kid
was 69. way too young
um
speaking of way too young and speaking
of Kevin's that passed away
uh sadly we lost another Kevin just this
week everybody uh and we all know who
that is uh that's the one true Batman
Kevin Conroy himself passed away 66.
way too [ __ ] young uh I did a eulogy
that that you know at a show recently
that we put up on the channel
um that's you know got a bunch of views
it's over a hundred thousand views at
this point somebody asked me I think I
was in Chicago
and somebody asked me about
the passing or technos Texas theater in
Dallas
somebody asked me about Kevin's passing
and you know I talked about some good
memories and kept it together and then
kind of broke down because
I've just been texting with them like
two weeks before
um
anyway you can go watch that video it's
uh it's uh
it's emotional stuff though so if you're
like what you're gonna cry again I mean
you'll have to excuse me not only was
the guy the voice of my hero but I knew
the man and the man was wonderful
um I worked with them I got to put them
in things
um Jane's Silent Bob's super groovy
cartoon movie just a voice a voice that
still to this day makes me laugh
um I he's in yoga osers you know he
deserved better but still he's in yogos
I worked in the Masters of the Universe
um I had him on an epic episode of of
Fat Man on Batman where like you know he
gave me advice and the voice of Batman
um he was a wonderful friend it's it's
rare that you get to
meet the people whose work inspires you
or his work you love and and uh you know
because of what I do for a living I got
to meet
the guy who's voice will forever be
Batman to me when you know us
from by the end of season one of Batman
the Animated Series
anytime I read a comic book Kevin
Conroy's voice as Batman was the voice
that I heard that's how good he was
so exceptional at the job that even
though Kevin's gone
I'll hear his voice
till the end of my life anytime I any
time I read a Batman comic his voice
comes through some people like not
Affleck I mean no with all due respect
to Ben who I absolutely adored and I
hear look here I'll do you one better I
don't even think in my own voice I think
in Affleck's voice
he's the narrator of my daily life so
that I love Ben make no bones about it
that being said when I read Batman in a
comic the voice I hear is Kevin Conroy
for heaven's sakes uh as a photo JC put
up of the Batman statue in uh Burbank
uh got a bunch of flowers at his feet
um that started happening almost
immediately when the news got out
I found out from uh
the folks I worked with at Masters
Universe Teddy and Rob
uh texting me and
um it was honestly a shock by virtue of
the fact that like
I'd just been texting with him about
coming to smodcast Castle
we were going to show like a couple
episodes and then of the animated series
and then deep dive with him
so um yeah [ __ ] man like
you know everyone's always like who's
the best Batman and I've always
always defaulted with Kevin comrade and
like wow
but movie Batman like Kevin Conroy was
in the movies
was a movie
you know there's no two ways about it
Kevin Conroy and and it's not
he had more time with the role nobody
has played Batman more than Kevin Conroy
in this world so I don't give a [ __ ] you
know who doesn't live action whether
they get three bites at the Apple or
whatnot Kevin Conroy got to do it again
and again and again he found the
humanity in the back
um he found the the humanity and Bruce
Wayne
um he also found the [ __ ] Darkness
man like his was a voice that you
listened to
and a no [ __ ] around [ __ ] around and
find out boys but it could be equally as
comforting in the time of trial or the
worst moment of your [ __ ] life his
Batman had all different shades and if
you want to you know see
Batman and his most comforting watch
that episode with uh
you know Ace it's from the Justice
League episode Amanda Waller is telling
uh Batman Terry McGinnis I believe the
story of Bruce Wayne who she knows Bruce
Wayne to be
and uh they're sending him in to deal
with Ace of the Royal Flush Gang who's
telekinetic and and you know destroying
Gotham making it a version of Alice in
Wonderland you know Wonderland it's a
Batman's got a device that's meant to
like kill this kid and he goes in and
has a conversation with her and
it you know even now as I just setting
up the scene I'm starting to [ __ ] get
emotional
um
watch it it's all over Twitter it would
resurface every twice a year it felt
like on Twitter where people be like
this scene's [ __ ] amazing and it is
it's uh Stellar [ __ ] work but that's
all
Kevin did he imbued a cartoon character
with a real sense of humanity that you
know I love Adam West don't get me wrong
but Adam West was playing something
large you know and he was the White
Knight the bright Knight not the White
Knight that sounded terrible sorry uh
the bright night as he used to say as
opposed to The Dark Knight
but he was always kind of you know
playing an arch version of the character
you know everyone else kind of leans
heavily into the voice
you know and Michael Keaton did
something interesting with a baffled
Bruce Wayne
um you know Christian Bale did something
interesting with a haunted Bruce Wayne
but Kevin Conroy's Bruce Wayne and
Batman
are
you know Bar None the best incarnations
of the character ever played like
I'll hear his voice for the rest of my
[ __ ] life man he
he got to do a lot with the character he
really got to explore the depths of that
character's Humanity in a [ __ ]
cartoon
mind you this conversation we're having
is about a [ __ ] cartoon and this guy
was that good
um and I'm happy to report that as good
as he was as his job
he was a beautiful [ __ ] human being
too he's a really good [ __ ] guy super
sweet anytime I want him I needed him to
come do a thing or called he was there
um never had a bad unkind word to say
about anybody happy
you know he had his problems he was
dealing with and stuff but always
chippered stuff Broadway kid right so
those kids tend to see The Sunny Side of
Things man you know because Broadway
musicals are nothing but [ __ ] hope
and love and [ __ ] and that's what Kevin
Conroy was hope and love incarnate
lucky to have had him as our Batman in
this simulation of a lifetime and stuff
but I'm far luckier to have known him
personally and
lucky to have known him at all
you got some experience with Kevin
Conway I've never met him I've never met
him I mean my my experience is purely as
a fan you know because to your point he
got to play Batman longer and and live
more depth than anybody else did you
know and through almost every media you
know to see him in the crisis in
infinite Earth as sort of old Bruce
Wayne to see him in live action
like donning the suit a little bit you
know was just wonderful because yeah he
got to do it all God bless orlante and
the CW shows because it afforded him an
opportunity that he was not going to get
in the DC movies they let him be Batman
he put on
the the gear and [ __ ] in action it was
sweet man the uh Kevin Rubio the great
Kevin Rubio
um just said in chat the scene that I
was talking about with the ace and
Batman was ended by the late great
Dwayne McDuffie another [ __ ] black
man Legend who's passed yeah
um I think one of one of the
the episode of Masters that I wrote
um the most dangerous man in Eternia
um had two amazing [ __ ] voice rules
in it you know the first of which I knew
was going to be there which was oh it's
Mark Hamill the Skeletor and so I got to
write a little bit of skeletal that was
just who to listen to it including one
of the greatest lines in the series
which made it all the way through to
like the [ __ ] the record all the way
through the finished product him a
Skeletor going what if we painted this a
nice granite
so silly
um but the surprise was that that Kevin
Conroy was playing merman
you know and so to to sort of turn in
tune into my episode and listen to
suddenly Batman is is talking to me
um saying words that I wrote honest
Batman that would have been you know too
much icing on an already wonderful cake
but uh but even still just just to have
been
you know walking in the same Arena as
one of the best to ever do it
um
it's just just wonderful you know and
yeah like is his is the voice that I
hear when I read back
you know that's the one in my head
um and so consequently his is the voice
of the Batman that's closest to me
Tila princess of parrots in chat said
Adam West played Batman the longest
Kevin Conroy played him the most
did two animated films shortly before he
passed so I guess the logic here is
longest in time but it's like not
consecutively
right we played Batman for two years
three years during the live action then
you know a couple [ __ ] superhero
roasts but generally
not again until the animated things I I
think it's I think it's semantics there
Tila I think uh I think it's safe to say
that
Kevin Conroy played Batman the longest
and the most longest running
yeah to get into a really weird little
look at an IMDb and be like oh no you
played in 1968 and then 19. we're just
we're all separated by a Common Language
aren't we English wait but yeah um
and especially reading that story that
he wrote for DC's Pride issues yeah that
was just this year he got a bunch of
smart you know where he just revealed
that you know Batman saved his life
because he had been you know a a
closeted actor for most of his career
and it was Batman that sort of gave him
license to be able to be the him that he
wanted to be that by by playing a
character with such Duality
um did he realize that he didn't want to
have to be that person
um which is beautiful you know like
Batman meant this much to him as his
Batman seemed to admit to everybody else
damn sure
yeah it just [ __ ] sucks to lose good
people and he was a good person man
really good person a hell of a [ __ ]
actor and God damn it if his
still like you're talking about a show
that's like over 25 years old at this
point those episodes still [ __ ] hold
up am I like you know we were watching
Bugs Bunny when we were kids and our
parents were like I used to watch that
[ __ ] in a movie theater
they'll be watching Batman the Animated
Series long after we leave this world
people will be introduced to Kevin
Conroy's performance over and over again
just like we were introduced to Mel
Blanc you know
he'll live forever in the work and
that's part of the fun of doing what we
do is
you know if you're lucky enough to be
able to be in a thing
you know that's
filmed or recorded or whatever
captures a perfect moment in time we'll
always hear him at his absolute best
yeah you know the the weirdness of
legacy is that usually you're you're
planting seeds in a garden you never get
to see right but he got to know
while he was here that he was so many
people's favorite Batman
he knew that
the initial visual batch in in uh in
chat said there's an in memoriam before
the Animated Series now on HBO Max
that's sweet
that is really nice he deserves that and
so much more
um yeah man God damn it
uh Willie Jackson said uh Batman the
Animated Series is 30 years old
I guess this year yeah that's true 2022
it turned 30 this year wow 92. we're old
oh yes
quite
um
pour one out
for the greatest Batman who ever lived
thank you masked man
will not see his like again
sad man beyond tonight's his dance but
yeah just this part
just just a little bit
um
extraneous that Kevin Conroy's death was
the first celebrity death I got choked
up
I get a bit choked up over and I'm 41.
yeah I was well he was a celebrity to me
but he was also a friend I definitely
got choked up I cried like but that's I
know everyone's like sorry about you
[ __ ]
crying crying Kev Smith a cuck [ __ ] a
tuck [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ]
um there it is kids
there's your
fat man beyond for this week
Mark's got a thing to go off to so we're
not going to do any q a this week but
we'll be back
next week man the tour is uh easing up
uh I've got only four cities left
Phoenix oh three cities left Phoenix two
shows in Phoenix well the matinee sold
out night show of Phoenix Sunday night I
think there's still tickets left we're
doing a stand-up live then the Wilbur in
Boston
December 5th come see clerks three with
me on the convenience tour then Hartford
Connecticut
the uh day after December 6th and then
we're done with the tour so the dates
are getting few you know spreadier
um hey man what are you doing on Black
Friday kids come to smog Castle Cinemas
for the Zach and Marathon tickets are on
sale right now
it's a Zack and Miri without people like
what are you going to show Zach and Mary
a lot because they say Black Friday in
the movie that's not it at all
back in Marathon is this a marathon is a
26 mile race Zach and marathon is a 26
aisle race we got two Isles in the main
theater that means we could have 13
races to get to a total of 26 races two
Racers they start at the screen they
race all the way up to the top of the
theater
and we collect the times three best
times when bronze silver and gold then
we just watched Zach and Mary make a
porno
outstanding come on what are you gonna
do on Black Friday come out to Smart
Castle Cinemas my friends
and uh [ __ ] join the Zach and
Marathon you ain't got a race watch a
bunch of people they're gonna be signing
waivers I'll tell you that much
I think you're having too much fun with
this theater Kevin oh my God you that's
why the internet can say whatever they
want about me look he's a cook yeah I'm
a cuck with a movie theater [ __ ] you
there it is kids
there is your fat maybe I'm like give it
up for [ __ ] Banff man make this [ __ ]
happen thank you bamf man
hello
goodbye we'll see you soon uh give it up
to Mr Mark Bernardin without whom none
of this [ __ ] [ __ ] happens the captain
right there thank you
uh
clerks3.movie for tickets to Phoenix
Boston or Hartford kids
shy of that man quick stops and
masquerade in your local comic shop
right now
sport secret stash press we'll support
you
there it is
uh there's your fat man beyond for this
week we're back [ __ ] I'm back in my
basement from the 70s next I'm gonna go
[ __ ] lay on a water bed and watch
[ __ ] one day at a time in Alice put
your car keys in the Fishbowl y'all it's
a good time in this basement
damn skipping you're looking at the ice
storm just call me Ang leagues this is
the ice storm right here cool hangley
dangling brain
hanging brain there it is there's your
fat man beyond for this week for fat man
beyond
uh I'm Kevin Smith I am Mark Bernard
tune in next time same fat Time same fat
Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss all you dirty
little [ __ ]
wow
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]